Guten Tag.
Guten Abend Frau Doktor.
Guten Abend.
Du erst würde ich mich gerne vorstellen.
Mein Name ist Cervic.
Heute bin ich Ihre zuständige Ärztin auf dieser Station.
Und möchte mit Ihnen das Anamnesegeschickreffören.
Sind Sie damit anfrosht?
Ja bitte, ja bitte natürlich.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden nennen, bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Entschuldigung.
Kein Problem, Sie haben uns erhebt.
Ja, das gibt schon eine Zeit, eine Woche.
Okay, ja, schnell kommen wir Ihren Beschwerden.
Deswegen bin ich auch da.
Mein Name ist Ali Kurt.
Ali Kurt.
Ja.
Bitte, vor und nach Namen büster werden.
Anton Ludwig Ida.
Und Kurt, K-O-R-T.
Ich nehme an, Sie sind auch eine türkische Ärztin, oder?
Sie müssen noch diesen Namen kennen.
Ja, kennen ich schon.
Ausseherheit wollte ich noch mal fragen.
Okay, danke schön.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kurt?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Wahnsinn, Sie sind auch geboren?
Am 22. August 1981.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Muss das jetzt wirklich sein, Frau Doktor?
Ich komme hierher, bin ziemlich kaputt und Sie fragen mich nach meiner Größe.
Es tut mir echt leid.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, aber diese Informationen brauche ich,
um richtige Medikamente, Dosierungen rechnen zu können.
Ja, je, wenn es unbedingt sein muss, dann ist klar.
Also ich bin 1,73 m und 96 kg.
Okay, vielen Dank für die Angaben, Herr Kurt.
Ja, wer ist hier beschwerden, haben Sie?
Sie hören es, Frau Doktor, meine Stimme ist heiser.
Ich bin jetzt etwa 1 Woche alt.
In den letzten 3 Tagen ist es sogar schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Ich muss kräftig hustlen, aber das ist ein trockener Husten.
Es kommt überhaupt kein Schleim.
Okay.
Ich habe das Gefühl, der ganze Schleim klebt mir hier vorne auf der Brust,
insbesondere auf der linken Seite.
Und es wird immer schlimmer, habe ich das Gefühl.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Seit einer Woche haben Sie diese Husten, ist das wützlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, es hat zuerst, ich dachte zuerst, das ist ein Virager infäglich.
Ein bisschen Mutt, ein bisschen müde, Kopfschmerzen, Gliederschmerzen.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Nach 2-3 Tagen begann dieser Husten.
Und ich habe auch so ein komisches Pfeifen, wenn ich ausatme.
Es kommt der Husten.
Okay.
Sie hören das?
Ja.
Das sind die Kopfschmerzen.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich habe jetzt keinen Test gemacht,
aber es fühlt sich so an, ja, das stimmt.
Ich hatte das früher mal gehabt.
Bestät dieser Husten dauerhaft oder bekommen Sie Anfalls an?
Also das kommt immer wieder so anfallsartig.
Aber sowohl tagsüber als auch in der Nacht.
Immer wieder ein bisschen, dann habe ich ein paar Stunden Ruhe.
Und dann kommt es immer wieder.
Okay.
Haben Sie ein Auslöser bemerkt?
Ja, früher hatte ich ein Auslöser.
Also ich glaube, der Auslöser ist mein kleiner Sohn.
Er ist 6 Jahre alt und ist im Kindergarten.
Und er war vor mir krank.
Er lief die Nase und er hat auch geruscht.
Und ich denke, dass er mich angestellt hat,
dass ich es von ihm bekomme.
Wurde bei ihm irgendwelche Krankheit festgestellt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also wenn es Winter ist, ist das sehr langweilig.
Ich habe schon Schmerzen durch die ganze Wusterei.
Das wird mir der Hals schon weh.
Halsschmerzen auch haben wir gesehen.
Und was versteckt Ihre Schmerzen?
Schmerzen ist nicht so.
Also Schmerzen, ich nehme Ibuprofen.
2-3 Mal am Tag.
Das ist mir gegen die Schmerzen eigentlich sehr gut.
Aber wenn ich mich hinlege,
dann tu ich mich schwer zu atmen.
Also ich muss mein Brustkorb erweitern, um Luft zu bekommen.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass ich ersticke.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Was haben Sie beim anderen Arzt?
Ich dachte, es geht von alleine weg.
Ich bin jetzt noch nicht bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen.
Mein Hausarzt hat heute Nachmittag schon zu.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Okay, ich habe gute Entscheidungen getroffen.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Ja.
Gegen Schmerzen, das hilft.
Aber haben Sie andere Medikamente gegen Husten eingenommen?
Ich habe 1-2 Tage so Schleimlöser genommen.
Ich glaube, die hießen Ambroxol oder so ähnlich.
Ambroxol.
Hiebt das?
Ich habe da jetzt keinen Unterschied beim Werk.
Keine. Okay.
Haben Sie dazu Kurbschmerzen, geliederl, muskelschmerzen?
Ja, ja.
Und Brichkeit und Hallschmerzen?
Hallschmerzen eher wegen den Husten.
Den Stamm, den Husten, genau.
Okay.
Und wenn ich mich hinlege, dann kann ich mich auch so Husten anfangen.
Mhm.
Hinlegen, versteckt, ihr Husten, oder?
Ja, genau.
Außer Medikamente haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
dass ihr Husten, ihr Husten lindert?
Okay.
Wenn ich eine Tee getrunken habe, ich habe Honig probiert,
ich habe Vitamin C, ich habe frische Zitrone ausgepresst.
Ja, so sehr gut.
Es hilft gar nichts.
Vitaminen auch haben Sie eingenommen?
Ja, genau.
Sie hat keinen Unterschied.
Aber hilft nicht.
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden, Herr Kurt?
Ein, zwei Jahren hatte ich mal die richtige Drücke gehabt.
Das war die Influenza.
Da war es so ähnlich, aber damals war das viel schlimmer.
Ich hatte auch Schiebe gehabt, fast 40 Grad.
Diesmal habe ich eigentlich gar keinen Schieber.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen nicht, aber ich merke,
wir sind hier rasselt auf der Linken Seite.
Wie ist rasselt?
Wie der Schleim, wie der Schleim.
Bleibt vor.
Genau, das geht hoch und runter und das hört man.
Das ist so.
Haben Sie Atemnot auch?
Das an sich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Und fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Oder haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, Fieber habe ich jetzt nicht,
aber ich fühle mich so matt und so schrass.
Okay.
Leiden Sie runter, Schütterlfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Noch nicht, aber ich habe Angst, dass es irgendwann kommt.
Ja, ich hoffe, das kommt nicht.
Wir werden Ihnen helfen.
Ich hoffe, deswegen bin ich dabei.
Ich habe große Hoffnung, Frau Doktorin Sie.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Und in die Klinik.
Unbedingt helfen wir Ihnen.
Aber ich habe ein paar allgemeine Fragen.
Erst mal, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, ich habe es halt gestern, ein bisschen wie Ihnen Appetit.
Seit gestern.
Ja, aber ansonsten war das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ansonsten haben Sie am Gewicht ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, nein, nein, alles gleich.
Wie ist Ihr Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Das ist kein Problem.
Alles gut.
Okay, das freut mich.
Leiden Sie unter Überkeit oder haben Sie schon einmal erbrochen?
Nein, nein.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, wenn ich sehr stark huste,
dass so ein gleicher Würgerreiz kommt.
Aber verbrochen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Nach husten verschwülern Sie die Würgerreiz.
Ja.
Und kratzen im Hals.
Das gibt einem das Gefühl, aber verbrochen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut in der letzten Zeit?
Also in der Nacht muss ich auch ständig husten und werde dadurch immer wieder wach.
Ansonsten habe ich davor keine.
Schlafen Sie nicht gut in der Nacht?
Okay.
Gut, haben Sie zu Hause einen Corona-Test gemacht?
Nein, nein, habe ich leider nicht.
Okay.
Den Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Letztes Jahr hatte ich mich geimpft, ja.
Wie viel mal?
Gesamt vier mal, glaube ich.
Okay.
Und auch sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ach so.
Aufrichtung, Impfungen, haben Sie machen lassen?
Ja, also da habe ich im Prinzip alle Impfungen, das stimmt.
Ja, okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Hausarztregelmäßig?
Ja, der schaut immer nach und sagt, das ist in Ordnung.
Okay.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen, Herr Kurt.
Leiden Sie an dauerhaften Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit
oder erbliche Krankheiten könnte sein?
Also mein Rad sagt mir, ich bin eben ein bisschen übergewichtig,
aber und er hat auch mal gemeint, ich habe einen leichten, erhöhten Blutdruck.
Ja.
Ich habe noch nicht die Medikamente, und ansonsten war alles bisher in Ordnung.
Okay.
Wurde Ihnen keine Medikamente empfohlen?
Er wollte das erst mal beobachten, aber ich befürchte,
dass ich irgendwann mal Medikamente brauche, noch habe ich keinen.
Okay.
Und messen Sie Ihren Blutdruck?
Wie Sie.
Das ist in letzter Zeit nicht lang.
Okay.
Dann jetzt machen wir unbedickt.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Kurt?
Also, so Kinderoperation, so Glintambe und operierte Mandeln sind raus.
Und ansonsten, nein, keine Operation.
Beide Operationen waren in der Kindheit?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Wie schon gesagt, jetzt nur im Rahmen dieser Erkältung, aber ansonsten nicht.
Okay.
Heute Tage Ibuprofen und Abrokstol und Vitaminen haben Sie eingenommen.
Ansonst keine?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien bekannt, Herr Kurt?
Ja, ich habe eine Penicillinallergie.
Und ich habe eine.
Was war das?
Novalginalergie.
Okay.
Wie äußert sich die Allergien?
Also, bei Novalgien ist es ganz schlimm.
Da bekomme ich Luftnot.
Ich bekomme dann ganzen Ausschlag auf den Körper.
Und bei Penicillin, dabei komme ich immer durchfallen.
Okay.
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig für uns.
Vielen Dank für die Angaben.
Und noch andere Lebensmittel oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Okay.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten, Herr Kurt.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Wie viel Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Und seit wann?
Das hängt immer von der Arbeit.
Aber ich komme so ungefähr auf eine Packung pro Tag.
Wie lange?
Ich denke schon seit 20 Jahren.
Okay, das ist aber zu viel.
Ja, leider habe ich einen stressigen Job.
Familie, Beruf, das ist alles.
Ja, das kann mir gut vorstellen.
Aber wenn Sie damit aufhören, können wir Ihnen auch helfen.
Nach unserem Gespräch können wir darüber sprechen.
Probieren Sie aber zuerst, bitte, dass er behandelt und dann
diese aktuelle Beschwerden kümmern wir darum.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht so oft, manchmal, ja.
Manchmal? Was meinen Sie?
Ja, abends mal ein Bier oder manchmal auch zum Essen, mal so ein Wein.
Was ist jeden Tag oder nur ein Wochenende?
Einmal pro Woche, pro Monat.
Ich denke so am Abend, das ist für mich sozusagen eine Erholung.
Das ist jetzt nicht viel, Frau Dr.
Das ist eine Flasche oder zwei Flaschen.
Eine Flasche oder zwei.
Das beruhigt mich immer, das finde ich immer ganz gut.
Nach so einem stressigen Tag.
Also ein bis zwei Flaschen, aber nur abends.
Ich bin dann auch ganz klar.
Ich bin kein Alkoholiker, Frau Dr.
Wenn Sie das machen.
Natürlich nicht Alkoholiker, aber auch natürlich.
Manchmal halt zum Abendessen und wenn man mal weg ist,
dann trinkt man gerne mal ein Wein, ja.
Okay, dann auch können wir darüber später sprechen.
Jetzt frage ich eine Frage.
Eine Frage stelle ich.
Das ist eine ultimäßige Frage.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein.
Nein, okay, das freut mich.
Jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familiengeschichte sprechen.
Wie lange müssen wir noch sprechen?
Also ich kriege hier schlecht Luft,
wenn ich zumindest ein bisschen Sauerstoffer da irgendwas geben.
Ja, Sie, ich habe...
Reden und Reden, Entschuldigung, aber...
Okay, jetzt finde ich...
Sie sollten mir mal schauen,
zumindest mal die Lunge-Aprion, Frau Dr.
Natürlich werde ich Ihre Lunge-Aprion...
Geht mir das mit dem Gericht noch.
Okay, jetzt Ihre Kreislaufwerte
und Ihre Sauerstoffsättigung werden von Kollegen gemessen.
Das wäre mir sehr lieb, ja bitte.
Okay, bekommen Sie Sauerstoff über die Nase,
damit wir unsere Geschippelrefort fahren können, okay?
Ja, danke schön.
Und wie ist der Sauerstoffwert? Haben Sie jetzt gemessen?
Jetzt ist in...
ist alles in Ordnung, aber trotzdem gebe ich Ihnen Sauerstoff.
Das hilft Ihnen.
Also ich merke schon, das tut mir schon gut,
dieser Sauerstoff, ja.
Okay, ja, das freut mich sehr.
Warum haben Sie es nicht gleich gemacht, meine Güte von Doktoren?
Aber ich habe Sie gefragt,
und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Atemnot haben.
Deswegen, ich wollte unsere Gespräche zu Ende bringen.
Vielen Dank, das tut gut.
Aber ja, natürlich, Sie können jederzeit unterbrechen
und Ihre Befürchtung sein, das war sehr gut.
Und jetzt frage ich nochmal über Ihre Familie.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Krankheiten?
Also mein Vater, er hatte schon eine Prostata-Operation.
Ich glaube, das war sogar bösartig, ja.
Meine Mutter hatte ein Diabetes
und hat auch eine leichte Depression.
Okay.
Und sind beide am Leben, oder?
Ja, ansonsten geht es in gut, ja.
Okay, nach der Operation hat ihr Vater Chemotherapie
oder andere Therapien bekommen?
Nein, nur Operation.
Ja, weiß ich das nicht.
Das liegt auch schon, glaube ich, zehn Jahre zurück.
Das geht jetzt gut, das ist regelmäßig beim Arzt.
Und er meint immer, es sei alles in Ordnung.
Mehr habe ich nicht gesagt.
Das ist auch sehr fit.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Aber jetzt noch, Alter, der ist ganz okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Die ist topfit.
Sie ist Sportlerin, sie ist Lehrerin, also, ja, gar nichts.
Oh, sehr gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Kurt?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und ich habe auch zwei Kinder.
Zwei Kinder, ja.
Und Sie haben einen Sohn und noch andere Kinder.
Ich habe einen Sohn, eine Tochter, eine Sohn ist jetzt 14.
14 Jahre alt und die Tochter ist sieben.
Sie haben am Anfang 6-jährige Sohn erzählt.
Nein, habe ich nicht gesagt, kann ich mich nicht erinnern?
Kindergarten?
Entschuldigung, ja.
Der im Kindergarten ist ja, ja, ich habe es jetzt verwechselt.
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Der Sohn ist 6 Jahre und die Tochter ist schon 6 Jahre.
Tochter ist schon 6 Jahre und beide sind 5 Jahre.
Okay, was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Kurt?
Ich arbeite, ich bin Bauingenieur und mache Bauleitung.
Okay, Bauleitung.
Ja, vielleicht ein stressiger Beruf.
Oh ja, wir haben gesagt, das ist echt sehr stressig.
Okay, das verstehe ich.
Und ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen, Herr Kurt,
möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Vielen Dank, wenn Sie noch gleich noch einen Röhm können
oder irgendwas machen und schauen, was es ist,
das würde mich...
Ja, natürlich.
Das, was mir geben können, dass das mal weggeht.
Wie?
Dass ich mir irgendetwas geben, damit das weggeht mit den Husten.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht genauer sagen.
Erstmal werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und wird abnehmen und bildgebende Verfahren durchspulen,
natürlich diese Untersuchungen.
Was heißt bildgebende Verfahren, was ist das?
Diese Untersuchung, das kann durchspulen,
könnte sein und vielleicht je nach Ergebnisse können
wir, Thermografie vielleicht, daran lassen,
aber das ist noch nicht klar.
Nach allen Ergebnissen kann ich Ihnen noch...
Machen Sie das alles noch heute?
Das wäre sehr schön.
Ja, heute vielleicht könnte sein,
aber am Ende jetzt, ich bin nicht sicher,
ob Sie nach Hause gehen dürfen oder bei uns bleiben.
Nein, ich bleibe auch gerne da, es ist kein Problem,
Hauptsache es hilft.
Okay, das tut mich...
Erstmal alle Ergebnisse bekomme ich,
dann mich meine Oberarzt sprühen.
Okay.
Ich werde Sie am laufenden Halbjahr...
Wunderbar, super, das freut mich.
Okay, vielen Dank, Frau Dr. Leppert.
Okay, ich komme zu Ihnen gleich.
Ja, wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Ich habe einen Kollegen oder eine Kollegin noch eine Frage.
Ich werde Sie alle Fragen gestellt.
Hallo, millen wir, alle Fragen gestellt.
Okay, aufnahme.
Okay, sehr gut.
Schönen Abend.
Ah, unsere junge neue Kollegin.
Hallo Frau Doktor.
Hallo, liebe Obra.
Erzählen Sie mal, was haben Sie mitgebracht?
Ja, ich habe heute mit einem neuen Patienten,
das haben wir da gespürt und würde gerne Ihnen den Fall vorstellen.
Okay?
Ah, dann schießen Sie mal los bitte.
Es handelt sich um Alikurt.
Herr Kurt, sei 43 Jahre alt, am 26.08.1998,
1,73 m groß und 6,90 kg schwer.
Herr Kurt stellte sich heute wegen eines seit einer Woche bestehender
schleichend aufgetretener, progredienter, anfallsartiger,
anartigen trockenen Wusten bei uns vor.
Der Patient berichtet, dass er ein feinendes Geräusch habe
und darüber hinaus leider der Patient als Begulassentome
unter Erschöpfung, Defalgie, Arturalgie, Mialgie
und Disfalgie und in der linken Seite Toraxschmerzen.
Und als verstärkende Faktoren,
nannte der Patient hinlegen und verstärken sich
der Wusten in der Nacht.
Und die Einnahme von Ibuprofen,
so kleine Linderung mit Gegenschmerzen geführt habe,
aber die Einnahme von Abrok Sol gegen Husten zu keiner Linderung geführt.
Und der Patient, der Erwente,
hat ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt,
die vegetative Anamnese seit gestern
und Würgerreflex nach dem Husten und Schlafstörung bedingt der Schlafstörung.
Als vor Erkrankungen sei beim Patienten Arterialhypertonie bekannt,
aber bei den Patienten sei keine Medikamente empfohlen worden.
Als vor Operationen nannte der Patient eine Appendectomy und Tonselektomie in der Kindheit.
Die Medikamente anamnese ergab nuva gegen aktuelle Beschwerden, Ibuprofen, Abrok Sol und Vitamine.
Ansonsten nehmen er keine Medikamente.
Erkurt sei vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten und gegen Corona-4 mal.
Und er habe alle Auffälligungen impfungen machen lassen.
Beim Patienten sei eine Penicillin-Alargien, die sich diöröre und novalgien allergie,
die sich düstne und exantem äußere.
Die Reise anamnese sei unauffällig.
Erkurt sei rauher mit Einpackung, Zigaretten täglich,
eine Packung seit 20 Jahren, das beträgt 20 Packiers.
Und er trinke jeden Abend eine oder zwei Flaschen Bia.
Erkurt sei verheiratet,
die sich in der Erkurt verheiratet.
Erkurt sei ein
Die Analyse wurde verheiratet,
erbaut ein Genübchen vom Beruf und
hat zwei Kinder.
Die anonystische Angaben
durchführen auf die Pertis-Infektion.
Ah, okay.
Da, der Patient berichtet,
ein Kochkusten und
Anfallstätigen.
Okay.
Wie bestätigen Sie den Kochkusten?
Welchen Test machen Sie?
Ich rache abschätrig und östereologische Teste.
Okay.
Was kann es noch sein?
Es könnte,
als Differenzialdiagnose kommen,
eine griebare Infektion,
eine Influenza und Corona.
Eine ati-pische Pynomene
mit trockenen Kusten.
Sehr gut.
Sie wollen jetzt noch röntgen
und weitere Untersuchungen machen?
Ja, erstmal körpälich untersuchen,
eine Untermistung, Sauerstoffwerte,
Bestimmung.
Dann inspiriere ich den Patienten
als Bereich, ohne Bereich.
Und Blutgase werden, glaube ich, ganz wichtig.
Ja.
Aber als Laboruntersuchung,
Blutgase, Analyse,
war ich.
Sie haben erwähnt, der Patient hätte gesagt,
er hatte Schmerzen.
Weil das ist ja schon ein wichtiger Punkt.
Hatte jetzt links-toracale Schmerzen?
Oder war das etwas anderes?
Der Patient hat ein bisschen unspecifisch erklärt.
Rasseln am linken.
Er hat Rasseln.
Das sind aber keine Schmerzen.
Links-toracale Schmerzen ist ja eine instabile AP.
Rasseln ist ja etwas anderes.
Rasseln oder eine Spastik hat.
Dieses Pfeifen,
das spricht eher für ein pulmonales Problem.
Und links-toracale Schmerzen,
dann muss man auch an etwas kardiales denken.
Haben Sie schon einen EKG geschrieben?
Wenn Sie schon einen links-toracalen Schmerz ausgehen.
Ich hatte Schmerzen gesagt,
aber das war nicht richtige Schmerzen.
Der Patient erklärt etwas anders.
Ich glaube, der hat gesagt,
er hat das Gefühl, dass es alles zugeklebt ist.
Er hat es für schleimt.
Deswegen dachte ich nicht,
kardiales Patroen.
Ein feiner, aber wichtiger Unterschied.
Ich würde trotzdem bei ihm
ein EKG schreiben.
Der hat eine Nikotin-Anamnese,
trinkt Alkohol, stressiger Job,
hat ein Alter von 42, 45 Jahren.
Und wahrscheinlich auch hohen Blutdruck.
Der hat schon einiges an Risikofaktoren.
Ich würde da auch die kardiale Schiene
auch noch mal mitmachen.
Das heißt EKG und die Herzinzyme usw.
Welche weiteren Differenzialdiagnosen
oder an welchen weiteren Differenzialdiagnosen
denken Sie denn noch?
Das ist Gastroedophagiarreflugs-Krankheit,
Leitzrusten.
Leitzrusten, vielleicht ja,
aber der hat auch, könnte ich auch sagen,
genau durch den Reflux, dass man da durch ein Reizrusten hat.
Bakteriellen-Fektionen könnte sein.
Ober- und untere Atem-Mix-Infektate,
der bebruntet ist.
Das kann es noch sein.
Er hat eine Raucher-Anamnese.
Eine COPD, was noch?
Was bekommt ein Raucher im Verlauf?
Manchmal.
Ich habe noch eine.
Da ist ein Rauchauf.
Nein, muss man auch mal denken,
Rauchen, Rauchen,
die erste, woran man denkt,
wenn man lang erlang geraucht,
eine Pluridis, nein.
Eine Moturat.
Nein, denken Sie mal an das ganz
Schlimmes, ja, jetzt kommt es endlich.
Ja natürlich, ja, auch wenn der Patient jung ist,
kann ein Bruncher Karzium machen.
Und wenn ein Infekt etwas länger anhält und nicht weggeht,
woran denken Sie dann noch? Auf der Lunge und im Mediastinum und so weiter.
Und wo ist denn? Und wo soll sein?
Erstmal viral Infektion, aber dann secondaire Bakterie.
Noch ein etwas schlimmeres.
Ganz schlimmes ist Karzinom.
Ja, was gibt es noch als Schlimmes?
Nein, nein, nicht spontan.
Also ich sagte schon, Mediastinum.
Was ist in Mediastinum?
Was gibt es da viel?
Viele Lymphknoten.
Wenn Lymphknoten sich vergrößern, was kann es sein?
Das ist gar nicht.
Herr Karajowlan ist ein guter Arzt hier.
Herr Karajowlan, was sind Sie für ein Arzt?
Herr Karajowlan oder Frau Karajowlan?
Richtig, ein Lymphon.
Man muss auch mal an ein Lymphon denken.
Das ist eine Frau Karajowlan mit rosa Schrift.
Also, ein Lymphon, natürlich.
Kann auch mal sein.
Mediastinade vergrößert der Lymphknoten.
Vielleicht haben sie dann auch Lymphone
oder irgendwelche anderen Metastasen,
die in das Mediastinum metastasiert sind
und zu einer Lymphknoten metastasig geführt haben.
Man muss auch an einer anderen Malik eine Grunderkrankung
mit denken.
Aber das sehen Sie, wenn Sie einen CT machen,
dann sehen Sie ja für größere Lymphknoten.
Und Sie sehen auch gewisse Veränderungen im Blutbild.
Wenn Sie Labor abnehmen, dann sehen Sie auch.
Ich hatte eine weitere Differenzialdiagnose.
Ich hatte vor zwei Wochen eine Patientin.
Die kann mit ähnlichen Beschwerden, so wie jetzt,
Schlappheit, Schwäche, Müdigkeit,
nur wenig Frusten, aber richtige Schwäche,
Fieber nicht so ganz.
Und wenn man sie abgehört hat,
dann war linksbasal ein abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch.
Ich habe sie mit Verdacht auf einer atypischen Pneumonie
in die Klinik geschickt.
Und was kam raus?
Sie musste operiert werden
und da wurde viel, viel eiter entleert.
Wie nennt man diese Erkrankung, wenn viel eiter auf der Lunge ist?
Fast zwei, drei Liter.
Sie hatte Leuropozytten von 37.000 Euro.
Nicht Euro, 37.000.
Das Differenzialblutbild war für dich in Ordnung.
Die Granulozytten waren hoch.
Alles andere waren normal.
HSCRP.
Vatlosenten.
Bitte?
Vatlosenten, aber ist immer unter.
Linken Unterlappen.
Turbokulose ist der meisten, das ist im Urlaub.
Wie nennt sich diese Erkrankung, wo viel eiter drin ist?
MPM.
Sehr gut.
Keine Katergiorgan.
Wie ist das?
Oh, so.
Ein pleurer MPM.
Genau, richtig.
Daran müssen wir auch mal denken.
Da hat sich viel eiter.
Das ist manchmal nach einer abgelaufenen Pneumonie,
was nicht richtig abheilt.
Und dann ist der Unterladen verschlossen
und dann bildet sich viel eiter und brodelt
und kocht vor sich hin.
Aber die Patientin war erstaublich noch ganz, ganz fit.
Die musste in der Toraxchirurgie operiert werden.
Und sie hat gemeint, man hat ca. 3 Liter Eiter entleert.
Und man hat das immer wieder gespürt und gespürt und gespürt.
Und dann konnte sie endlich mal nach Hause.
Ein Grund sein für die MPM.
Natürlich, da ist meistens ein bakterielle Infekt dahinter.
Klar, Turbokulose kann mal sein
oder ein Lymphom kann mal sein.
Eine abgelaufene Lunge der Entzündung kann sein.
Eine Aspiration kann sein.
Eine nicht abgeheilte COPD kann sein.
Natürlich als irgendeiner Art von Infekt und Verschluss der Art im Wege.
Okay, ich glaube, das war es.
Mit meiner Seite gibt es von Ihrer Seite noch Fragen.
Okay.
Danke.
Und ich dachte aus Verdachtdiabnose per Tursis.
Aber ist das falsch oder was?
Kann schon sein.
Natürlich.
Es ist ein Kind da.
Es hat auch gehustet.
Das kommt auch wieder im Moment verstärkt, dieser Keuchhusten.
Wir haben schon ein, zwei Patienten gehabt.
Und wir haben eine junge Assistentenball in so einer Praxis.
Der hat auch immer kontrolliert fast jeden Patienten auf Keuchhusten.
Aber es waren nur zwei Patienten, die sind mit Keuchhusten.
Aber hier in Deutschland?
Ja, gibt es manchmal ja.
Nicht so oft.
Die meisten sind ja geimpft.
Aber trotzdem kann es manchmal sein.
Sie haben gesagt, Impfstatus ist voll.
Ja, genau.
Es ist eher unwahrscheinlich.
Ich denke, das Verdachtdiabnose ist eher ein viraler Infekt.
Ja, Verdachtdiabnose.
COVID-Infektion.
Also kommen wir, er wurde nicht pynomenä.
Aber ich will nicht krankenhaufen.
Ich bin Baunen-Junior.
Okay, das war sehr gut.
Vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Auf die.